hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to subnautica now in
the last episode I was a little bit
panicked considering that this is a new
environment and I'm a big bubble blowing
[ __ ] baby but that doesn't matter
because I have to go out there and I
have my c glide now which means that I
can see which is good and I've got a
mapping system I forgot that was in
there I never actually oh the Thunder
scares me I gotta get some food too so
I'm gonna take these guys um whoa wait
what if I get in oh no that's the same
drop as it was before okay is it bad out
there full oh my god oh my god that's so
cool I imagine that in the future
they're gonna have even more weather
systems available probably with like
snowstorms even though this is kind of a
snow storm under snow whatever it is
anyway well we got to do now is we got
to explore a bit farther we got to start
getting enough resources to build the
Builder tool we was that even an option
how do we remember whoa hey you deployed
hey good for you man prowl do you
alright um also I should probably build
another battery do I even have enough
for that probably not okay
I can't build the builder tool I don't
have the option to build a builder tool
yet so we're gonna forget about that for
now I'm gonna put some [ __ ] away because
I'm gonna be out collecting [ __ ] anyway
so um pretty much only need one of each
and then I'm gonna cook these guys into
food
buh-buh-buh-buh-buh okay what do you got
Yaya
all right good for me okay so I don't
exactly know where I'm going because I
need to get research projects to be able
to do what I need to do however I
imagine that the game is gonna want me
to just kind of go out and figure it out
for myself
now what that means I'm not a hundred
percent sure but I'm just gonna start
going and I'm and I'm just gonna see for
myself if I end up in a horrible death
situation which is very likely least
I've got the high oxygen tank ooh what's
down there oh oh it's just another hole
okay okay
hello oh you're deep down here Oh what
is that is that needed what is that
table Coral
do I need that probably need that right
for something anyway yeah yeah yeah I
need that for computer chips and whatnot
right I can't see [ __ ]
hello well that's comforting
all right cool
whoa weird Oh deep okay
there's probably a way to make the the
locations go away probably there we go I
don't need this anymore and I need to
see that okay good to know thank you
with this and my power I should be able
to get out of here I do want to make
another battery before I go ah
how far could I possibly go that I would
need another battery to get out I need
to go back to the research site I can't
let you why not
boss's orders we're trying to keep you
alive only because salaries cost less
than lawsuits it's all cynicism making
new friends down there sure they're just
not human the files are on your databank
and ooh is it please just tell me what
you find
and don't get me into trouble I don't
think I should be able to see that
through the clouds but Oh whoo hey all
right then
200 meters down where is that exactly
wait what do we what are we talking
about wait a minute
alien sanctuary in a twisty bridges what
are the twisty bridges I don't got
anything on the beacons I got a whole
lot of nothing I got a little bit of
dick and a whole lot of diddly Oh are
these the twisty bridges Oh
ah what is going boom what in the world
is blowing up there's got to be the
twisty bridge right oh hey you're fine
are you fine you look like you might be
lethal
Oh your lethal all right oh are you the
new thresher or whatever it was the
toothy thing hmm okay I think I'm in the
twisty bridges but I don't like being in
the twisty bridges the twisty Bridges
makes me feel like maybe I'm not in the
right place I'm gonna wait until sunup
and then I'm gonna go it is sunup and
that's just how bright it's gonna be
okay
all right well all right then we're
gonna go for it
this must be the twisty Bridges and she
said 200 meters down I'm just gonna hook
up Ivy Thanks you're right I am okay
that's great
hey what is this what is this what is
this that's the thing wow what did I get
what I get what did I get
what did I just get something I didn't I
didn't get anything for that what do you
mean I didn't get anything for that what
do you mean this is the thing that was
the thing that I just did I break
something is that what I was supposed to
oh my god
oh is that I don't know what that is
wait there was an oxygen down there
um Oh what is that I don't care I'm
getting the oxygen Hey okay it doesn't
care what I am okay that's fine I can't
lag
[Music]
okay all right
is this it oh my god oh my god huh what
is that that's important okay three
fifty fifty oh my god oh my oh no just a
whole lot of nope on that one I don't
know I'm here I don't know what oh my
god it's beautiful
oh my god
okay um I don't have a beacon ain't got
nothing I'm good oh I've got a whole lot
of nothing oh I'm not seeing nothing so
I don't know if I was supposed to get a
beacon I don't know but I don't have one
so yeah I don't know I don't know what
to do about that
all right oh I'm going the wrong way
holy [ __ ]
ah
okay I think we're fine I think we're
probably fine okay I'm just gonna get
back I'm gonna I'm gonna see if there
was anything that actually did appear in
the in the section to build [ __ ] because
what I need is the Builder tool but I
don't know if I'm gonna get that but I
did access something it just didn't do
anything you know what I mean it was
supposed to be something but nothing
happened I don't know what if we get
anything Oh
a rebreather now that's probably
important oh yeah no that's good because
then when I go deeper it's not gonna be
bad so that's good
I got a rebreather now that's good
that's very good also good and cook this
I guess all right rebreather absorbs and
recycles co2 into breathable air
conserves oxygen when diving deeper now
all that is is just a dumb [ __ ] that's
full I didn't think I would get full
this soon but oh well I guess I am I can
turn these these two big-ass things into
lube or something or one silicone one
Lube it better than the form that it's
in right now okay all right deployable
fools
no repair tool I don't have sulfur so I
don't even know how to do that a battery
yes I want to make a battery I want to
make two batteries actually just think
it sorry just in case you never know
what you're gonna need when you're gonna
need it okay let's put those there let's
put these away and we're good to go okay
let's get you out oh hey buddy hey buddy
hey buddy hey how you doing or whatever
all right
um it must be something down in those
quote-unquote twisty bridges they said
something about an alien something or
other I don't know why I don't know what
but I'm gonna stick my head in the hole
down there just to prove that I ain't no
[ __ ] I don't know why I have to prove
that but I'm gonna prove that you know
what you are not that scary
you're that scary all right no you can't
catch me though because I got this
alright let's go down I don't like the
ominous music swell that happens when I
go down here but I guess it's alright
all right what do we got let's get some
oxygen
there was a crevasse right here yeah
here okay all right
crevasse just go down go down
oh uh uh ting tang walla bing bang oh ha
ha hey oh hey OH
what is it the bottom I don't know what
that is I don't know I don't care I
don't care I don't know uh okay I'm just
gonna assume yeah [ __ ] righteous
we've got you on GPS you're close to the
sanctuary do you see anything some alien
structures dotted about I'll see where
they lead why what are you talking about
I haven't seen anything oh okay
ah ah yes I see I see I see yeah okay
all right I see I see okay yeah I don't
know what you're leading me into but I'm
not happy about it
I can tell you that tell you that data
downloads I don't have time to read that
okay it's not there anyway cuz it's
early access all right yes please good
thing they got all these oxygen plants
here
those are awfully handy those are real
handy
all right these seem to be leading
somewhere there's a couple of them
around here now I don't know what the
point of them is but they're here what
was that not seeing anything if I'm
hearing them might be outside in these
cave walls I'm not on our percent sure
but if it isn't then I'm of asking me
I'm about to meet them which will be
fine others found their entrance I think
hi what is that what what is that
oh I swear to god this game is scarier
than almost any horror game I've ever
played in my life all right here we are
this looks nice
just a nice normal cave where nice
normal people I can see are you alive or
a computer I I want to meet the people
who built this place what do you want
with you why casual suit the hardest
life you've met old Terry then people
will come for me I waited my life for
this I'm not your enemy
hello huh all right look real casual I
mean buy me dinner first as you oh ow my
legs I should have been sprinting I
forgot that I could sprint oh yeah okay
all right let's try that again take two
yeah so real casual um what is that
beacon by the way another Supply Drop
okay sure yeah whatever I didn't know
that I was gonna get another one yeah so
yeah like I was saying I'm not opposed
to staying here forever
in fact that was kind of in the last
game what I reserved myself to I didn't
expect to ever go home so the idea of
even staying in one place forever but
alive is kind of appealing you know you
gotta admit yeah you know what I'm
talking about
whatever you computer man don't know the
difference between an alive computer and
a dead person all right cool whoo that's
the thing Wow I've seen things like that
bug why
died peacefully Hey I can't turn back
you clothes man here die peacefully
that's a bit extreme
okay first you wanted me to stay here
forever and now you want me to die but I
guess you don't know the difference
between life and death we got a dr.
Manhattan over here and you're just a
big cube all right well I'm gonna go
touch this big green glowy thing how
about that here we go
wink hi how you doing hey you doing okay
oh yeah me oh I see I'm the vessel ah
oh my brain Thanks thank you for that
PDA not good enough for you I see no I
don't oh I know it hurts
what happened you and my head download
capacity was identified in your cerebral
cortex you're in my head it is
uncomfortable return me release the
force fields first return me or I will
destroy your orbital station why not do
it now
my survival trance increases if I do not
draw attention I don't think you have
the power I think you're scared I will
destroy you okay I'm experiencing
technical difficulties
do not move okay all right cool I want
move move right burro's huh how eventing
I didn't mean to scare you what's
happening
I wonder what would happen if I didn't
move would have been like a game
overseeing Lindsay would have figured it
out and then killed me that would have
been fun and then I would had to restart
but let's assume he wasn't gonna do that
so let's get out of here apparently
because that's what we're doing now I
have an alien inside my head or for some
reason he's gonna give me a lot of
knowledge of how to live in this frozen
world right probably yes and not kill me
okay Sam [ __ ] went down
um I'm in a bit of a spot of bother okay
not that weird noise again all right
cool
great these silver LED let that's silver
lead now silver god dammit I didn't even
get lead from the lead one I don't know
what I'd need let for but it's something
that I don't have yet so I figured that
it would have been nice to have these
silver cut damn where's the lead
it's the lad out lead no lead no lad got
lead okay I don't know what I need lead
for was that
so I think I know what all the kabooms
were I don't know how I could have
forgotten about the kaboom er the kaboom
er is kind of like that one thing that
you don't forget in this game right up
there with leviathans but I forgot about
it
so that's my bad so yeah Sam I am in
trouble I'm in a bit of goddammit no
kaboom
oh wait I don't need anything thank you
I'm good
apprec-- free [ __ ] whoa you got clothes
where did the does another drop what the
Frick okay whatever I don't know what's
happening I don't care what's happening
I don't need to know what's happening I
just want to get out of here
it's storming like crazy whatever
Lissa's get back I need to talk to Sam
cuz something happened
real bad okay there's two supply drops
where's this other one oh oh no that's
isn't that the one that I already saw
yeah let me go check it first it's not
too far away I think that's the one that
I think that's the one that uh that it
wanted me to get anyway I think I
already got that one
boy this place is just this place is
just full of death oh no it's not it's
different
what are you oh all right cool
Oh heating gel I get to smear myself
with Joe I get to smear myself with gel
that's awesome
I love smearing myself that's like my
favorite thing to do a lot of smears all
right whatever I haven't experienced
anything to do with a cold yet but maybe
I have and I've been dying slowly to
something that I don't reckon there you
bet I already Targo rockin I'm on it
cargo rocket cargo rocket cargo rocket
hmm I those words just really not making
a lot of sense to me I hey you in there
we're in trouble
if your center sample your monsters will
come to us they'll do the same if I
don't return me to the same area so you
can trap me again No then I will mask my
presence initiate the scan Oh am I
supposed to do this myself err or am I
supposed to do this with the thing that
they send
all right um oh there we go
is that coming down all right let's find
out what that is all about and then I'll
replace the battery once this gets dead
hey wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait a minute
okay yep nope oh you do I really have to
wait until you fall down that really
what I have to do here that really what
I have to do I look the flashlights
light better it's very very nice very
comforting very surrounded by Death
come on hurry up man hurry up all right
portable wow that's not what I thought
it was gonna be bioscanner huh it's got
a big glowy penis on it Sam I've got the
sample looks normal how do I do that
should it be well do you got it Sam 200
500 all right fine I'm gonna dump some
stuff in this storage this storage
locker to speak
just because it's convenient storage
it's actually quite large I'm just gonna
put a bunch of stuff that I don't
immediately need for survival like a
dead battery
maybe there's gold titanium you know you
don't need that I could always get that
date him yeah yeah yeah whatever okay
let's go to the cargo rocket then I got
nothing better to do I got a bad feeling
about where it's gonna be but you know
oh no it's gonna be on an island
interesting is it it looks like it's
above the waterline so I'm just I'm just
assuming maybe huh you know what I'm
gonna miss you know what I'm gonna miss
the big floating turds the big old
things to fall in love with my my uh my
cyclops wow you guys really don't need
to blow up that much whoa hey it's a
fresh that's a thresher that's one of
those things hey I know you
Wow Hey whoa hey whoa hey whoa all right
Wow hey what water yo water you rock
puncher wait I swear I've seen this guy
before
Oh what do you do punch rocks you punch
my face Wow all right note to self don't
don't mock the indigenous life forms am
I going up Wow okay here I am Wow look
at that glacier that's beautiful um yeah
the cargo rocket huh about that ooh a
heated pool all right he thinks that
this is a bit unfinished maybe just a
wee tad bit hello how are you good to
see you hello how are you yes yes yes
very warm yeah I don't think that they
properly implemented Oh up there
yeah I don't know if they properly
implemented like the cold system just
yet or maybe it hasn't gotten cold
enough quote-unquote because it's kind
of raining right now and once this gets
cold then I'll need to do something
about that but for now it's awfully
comfortable oh I love the old system of
climbing up a mountain through a series
of unknown caves all right see above
water no scary no scary at all safe so
safe so fun and free and safe Hey
Wow oh hey wow this place looks great
this looks really great
umm this is great this is great yeah
this is great all right hello can I get
some coffee I can yes please single wall
shelf oh you know it baby
I got coffee
a quad coffee chair Locker I mean this
is a pretty good base here actually
surprisingly oh hey lockers all right
let me get this single bed Saul I'm
gonna need in this adventure
[Music]
Oh what am i skin and I don't know why
I'm scanning but it's probably important
no no no no no no no all right well we
got up here hello
I can't go up here all right never mind
I didn't want to anyway I didn't even
need to go in this place nice can that
no all right well I didn't know exactly
why I was supposed to be here in the
first place but I don't think this is
the rocket I think it's probably farther
up hello hello oh that's who you fancy
who are you fancy alright okay alright
well well well fancy schmancy Oh rocket
needs four god damnit are you kidding me
I need to get the repair mods whoo I
don't have sulfur where am I gonna get
sulfur okay I don't have all right I get
it I don't know where to get sulfur
though what am I supposed to do about
that all right there's no like this game
just came out there's not gonna be any
Maps it'll look good so wait of course I
was in the sulfuric vents of the area oh
I can't just jump off this mountain of
course of course in the sulfuric vents
of course it makes so much sense I'm
gonna die others I die sorry i sorry
that there's our die oh this is our day
okay but if I go to the sulfuric vents
that we're just here of course there
would be sulfur in those vents probably
that makes sense right
probably that's why it was in between
here and there I don't have enough of
the other stuff that I need probably
what do I need for up honey for a repair
thing pair tool just titanium ayah I
even brought the silicone rubber even
though I didn't think that I would need
it
cuz I'm weird like that and apparently
it pays off how about a fault i'ma die
Oh Kevin now if I could just get by
those goddamn threshers all right here
go help me all right so there's sulfur
here I mean this looks like it would be
a sulfuric vent type deal that's generic
OSHA whew oh hey are you doing okay all
right so that's just an arrow there what
would I feel like there would be
something here sulfuric right by these
vents it would make sense like I've
never seen suffer before but can't do
that can't be that weird right it's
gotta be obvious
maybe not obvious but whoa whoa uh-oh
you watch me I thought they weren't
hostile but apparently they're hostile
okay no no no no no no no no no okay um
no no thank you
all right so what is this magnetite all
right that's not what I'm looking for
but at least that's different boy things
seem to be a little bit broken here but
that's okay I'll Wow Wow Wow
oh I can go through that I did not think
I could go through that okay ooh don't
like that but maybe down here was that
that's nothing oh well that doesn't
sound good
whatever that is it's a bit of a dead
end here oh this goes down oh it goes
down all right oh hi how are you okay
never mind
all right so not down there I don't
think anything's down there they it
looks like they just haven't finished
putting things in that area ah of course
okay I looked this up just in case it's
um it's the thing is that is left over
after the Boomer right
so once the Boomer goes boom apparently
you go get it from the yeah if from the
little plant that it comes in so yeah so
I got a go back and I got a trigger one
of the boomers to come get me
I think they were actually in here so
it's nearby yeah so come get me
what okay 30 where oh hey okay don't
mind me don't mind me domain me okay
that worked out really well do I just
need the one I really hope I just need
the one I think I just need the one do I
just need the one there's something
after me I'm I'm good baby I'm good
let's go let's go let's go let's let's
go let's let's go and why do I gotta set
up a bio sample of myself why don't they
seems like a big waste of resources to
send just a little itty bitty sample of
myself I don't even know what it is
green and bubbly look at it this is a
weird green blob I'm sending this up in
a rocket this is this is worthy of a
rocket launch to get off of a planet
yeah whatever I'm I don't make the rules
here resource resources seem to be a
little improperly spent but it's not my
department so I'll be back once I get to
the fabricator alright hello my hands
not really on that but that's okay I got
psychic powers with this alien in my
head hello may I have one repair tool
please thank you kindly go to hell hope
you die
alright looks like we're gonna be
repairing this thing at night can i why
did I just go in water I'm not a
messenger but I'm gonna put this on five
we're gonna go there we're gonna go I
feel I still feel slightly concussed
for being punched by a horrible rock
crab creature of some kind but I think
I'm gonna be able to do some really
clever engineering here perfect
easy popper in popper in baby popper in
good thing that yeah oh yeah send her
off let's get this bad boy launched
nothing like a night launch go baby no I
mean 5 4 3 2 1 10 9 8 7 6 ok
liftoff she understood why don't you
come get me now why don't you take a
jaunt down here remind yourself that
life comes in colors besides white
off-white and gray she said the fading
of freezing to death if you're staying
on the ice you'll need transport will I
you're trusting you with a snow fox if I
can find a version of the truth that
authorizes it you're amazing yes her
she's amazing
promote this person why are you breaking
up love you I don't know what cool I
don't know now what what do you mean
it's two titanium to build a rock just
two titanium that's it to build a root
kit literally two titanium is all I need
to build a rocket in this economy I
can't believe it it's gonna hurt come on
okay I am stuck yeet ow
alright so that's good but I gotta get
home
cuz I'm it's dark and oh no I gotta get
home in the dark okay so I know that
there's no leviathans from point A to
point B so it shouldn't be too much to
consider that I just go from A to B
maybe I don't think there's anything
else to be done and besides probably
wait for them what are you doing hey you
want to talk to me uh-huh uh-huh I'm
sorry for bothering you I'm very sorry
I'm gonna fall off a cliff aren't I no
I'm good okay yep yep okay oh wow that's
is uncomfy okay
I'm good on pretty much everything at
this point there's only a few threshers
I don't think anything can catch me when
I'm going with this thing and for all I
know they haven't even put a Leviathan
in this game yet you know that they're
gonna subnautica devs they love their
leviathans like you know that's that's
definitely a fixture in this game but
what I really miss you know what I
really miss is having like the constant
landmark of the ship I mean it's good to
have like the mountain and that's that's
kind of nice because it is a landmark
but at the same time there's a lot more
land here like you just feel like this
more land it doesn't feel nearly as
isolated I don't know maybe that makes
it worse in ways that I don't understand
yet but for now it seems like hey maybe
things ain't so bad after all
you know what I mean yeah you probably
know what I mean is this the one I left
things in cool I don't think I need
anything from here so I think I'm okay
oh okay back home yeah
Altair I was listening I covered our ass
and she's my sister not my master you do
not trust your sister are you can you
read my thoughts listen I am thrilled to
meet you and I would love to help you
but you need to get out of my head
if you'll not return me you must release
me to another vessel love it how your
brain is a restrictive I will inform you
when I process the data
I'll keep Altair off our backs till then
it were more polite when we met yeah
process that I will try
okay it is interesting having a
narrative going on in this game because
the first game was so much about
isolation it's kind of what I said about
having that big ship there are no
landmarks anywhere it made you feel
really isolated I mean there were
islands in the first game but this one
like you definitely don't feel nearly as
isolated number one you're talking to
your sister from like the beginning of
the game and number two you've got an
alien in your head that's an experience
that pretty much nobody gets to have and
I don't know if I should feel special
about that but I kind of feel a little
bit special about that so in the
meantime it looks like I have to explore
and I don't like the idea of exploring
but supposedly I have to explore great I
will hard pass okay hard pass that's
enough for this episode I think I need
to get my braveness up a little more
before I go to Explorer because I'm
about to go outside of the boundaries of
places that I know and I don't know how
that's gonna go for me but I'm going to
find out so thank you everybody so much
for watching let me know what you
thought down the comments below as soon
as I figure out how to build lockers
again I'm gonna get names going on
lockers again so thank you everybody so
much for being here
hope you enjoying it expect a new
adventure to start next time thanks
again is all zai and as always I will
see you in the next video
[Music]